Once upon a time, there was a gorilla with wings.
One night, he flew out of the crazy zoo.
The next morning he flew to the ice cream truck...
...and bought a gigantic chocolate ice cream.
After eating the ice cream, he went to the park.
In the park, he saw a pink gorilla.
The flying gorilla went to the pink gorilla and said,...
..."Hi, do you giggle?"
"Yes, of course."
Knock, knock.
Who's there?
Gorilla.
Gorilla, who?
Gorilla me a hamburger.
After two weeks, they both started to attend animal school.
They were both in the same class.
The gorillas were learning math.
1, 2, 3.
There are two bananas.
Science, ELA and music.
After two months, the gorillas graduated.
During the graduation celebration, they did the gorilla stretch.
Their professor said they were geniuses.
Three months after, they fell in love then they got married.
The husband tried to search and guess where his wife was.
After the marriage, their genes were filled with love.
The end.